[SQUEAKING][RUSTLING][CLICKING]
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Today, what we're
going to do is continue our
discussion of factor markets
by essentially talking about
how capital markets impact
real world decisions.
So last time, we talked
about the capital market.
We talked about,
essentially, the way
that firms finance
their capital is
by going to a pool of
savings that individuals
decided how much to make.
Individuals make it
into temporal choice
on how much to save.
Actually, technically,
they can make a choice
about how much to
consume each period.
That then yields an
amount of savings.
And then based on
that pool of savings,
firms borrow at some
interest rate, i,
and they decide
how much to invest.
Now, today we're going
to talk about a number
of interesting
applications that arise
from capital markets that are
important in the real world.
And I'm going to
start by talking
about the concept
of present value.
Present value.
Now, the key insight when we
think about capital markets
is that $1 tomorrow is
worth less than $1 today.
$1 tomorrow is worth
less than $1 today.
That's because if you
had the dollar today,
you could productively invest it
and have more than $1 tomorrow.
So $1 today is worth
more, because you
could do something productive
with that $1 if you had it
today.
What that means is that
dollars in different periods
are worth different things.
You can't just add them up.
OK, the analogy I like
is thinking about--
imagine you had a pound of
apples, a pound of steak,
and a pound of gold.
You wouldn't just add them up
and say, I have three pounds.
That'd be useless.
You'd want to know
what each is worth,
and you'd want add up
the dollar value of them.
It's a similar thing with
money received over time.
You can't just say, I'm
getting $1 today, $1 next year,
and $1 five years from now.
They aren't the same thing.
Money received at
different points of time
are worth different
amounts, because money
received in the future forgoes
the possibility of investing it
today.
So what do we do
to deal with this?
Well, in economics,
we deal with this
by the concept of present value.
Present value is the value
of every period's payments
in terms of today.
So the way we deal with the fact
that money in different periods
is worth different amounts is
by what we call discounting it
back to today.
We essentially
take future dollars
and discount them back to
today to get present value.
We discount them, because
future dollars are worth less.
So let's think of it this way.
Suppose that the
interest rate is 10%.
Let's do an example.
Imagine the interest
rate, i, is 10%.
And let's say that you want
to have $100 next year.
Next year, you
want to have $100.
Well, how much do you have
to put in the bank today?
Well, we can solve the
equation, which is that you want
the amount you put in the bank
today-- let's call that y--
times one plus
the interest rate,
because that's what you make
by having it in the bank,
equal to 100.
That's the equation
we want to solve.
The money amount
you put in today, y,
times one plus
the interest rate.
You want that to
be equal to 100.
So what that says is
that y equals 90.9.
If you put $90.90 in the bank
today at a 10% interest rate,
you will have $100 tomorrow.
More generally, we say
that the present value
of any future payment
is the future value,
the amount you get in
the future, over one
plus i to the power
little t, where
t is the periods in the future.
So money received t
periods in the future today
is worth the amount you get
in the future over one plus i
to the t.
So that is our general
formula for how
we think about present value.
Take all the future payments,
and you discount them
back to today by dividing
by one plus i to the t.
Now, that works well if there's
one future payment coming.
But what if, as in
many cases, there's
a whole stream of
future payments coming?
Well, the logic
then is the same.
You just want to take
each future payment
and discount it by how
far it is in the future.
So suppose that you say that
you want me to loan you $30
and that you'll pay me back $10
each of the next three years.
And suppose the
interest rate's 10%.
Well, I will say no to that.
Because I will say,
if you're going
to pay me back $10 each of
the next three years, then
what is the present
value of that?
The present value is
next year's $10 over 1.1,
because the interest rate is
10%, plus the $10 the year
after that over 1.1 squared,
plus the $10 the year
after that over 1.1 cubed,
which if I add it up, is 24.87.
So I am losing money.
If I give you $30 today
and if you give me
$10 back each of the next
three years, I'm losing money.
Why?
Because if I had
simply taken that money
and invested it in
the bank, I would've
had a lot more than
the $30 I'm going
to get from you
after three years.
OK, so the money that
comes in the future
must be discounted
back to today.
That's the key insight
of present value.
You can't just add it up.
You've got to put
it in today's terms
by discounting it
by the interest rate
and how far into the future.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So aside from
just the change in value
that's caused by interest, how
do you take into consideration
the fact that the value
of the currency itself
hasn't changed over time?
JONATHAN GRUBER: We're
assuming now inflation is zero.
So we're assuming
right now, we're
not dealing with inflation.
We're assuming a world
where prices don't change.
We'll come back to
inflation in a few minutes.
But for now, just assume
that prices don't change.
OK, so basically,
essentially, the formula
then for the present
value, your general formula
for present value
you need to know
is that present value equals--
if you get a flat
stream of payment
f for a number of periods,
it's f times one over one
plus i to the one
plus one over one
plus i squared plus
one over one plus i
cubed plus dot dot dot dot
dot dot for how many periods
you get it.
So if you're getting a payment
f over a certain number
of periods, you've
got to discount it
by how many periods
you're going to get it.
Or more generally,
a common formula
we'll ask you to
use in this class
is to think about the
formula for perpetuity.
A perpetuity is a flat
payment you get forever.
So if we take the infinite
sum of this equation,
we can summarize it as present
value approximately equals
f over the interest rate.
So if I promise you to pay you
forever a certain amount f,
that is worth f over
the interest rate.
So in other words, if
the interest rate is 10%,
a promise to pay you $10
forever is worth about $100.
That's just the Infinite sum.
If you've read A
Beautiful Mind, John Nash
can do that in his head.
But I can't, but that's
just the formula.
So basically, that is the
general formula for perpetuity.
And that makes life easy.
We'll give you a
lot of examples.
Because if I say I
want you to pay me
for eight years in
the future, I've
got to write out
eight terms here.
It's a pain in the ass.
So what we'll say
is money forever,
and then you'll just
use the shortcut,
which is the present
value for perpetuity.
It's just f over i.
Questions about that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does this also assume
the rate of change over time?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
That's a great point.
Yes, I'm assuming constant
interest right over time.
Now in reality, you'd want to
have each period's interest
rate here, and then you
can't use this formula,
because the interest
rate itself is changing.
Very good point.
OK, now the other way
to think about this
is instead of
thinking just-- this
will be easy for most
of you, but just it's
useful to think it through.
Let's flip it on its head and
not think about present value.
Let's think about future value.
This is a useful tool as well.
Let's flip it on its head.
OK, so let's think
about the value
of a future stream of payments.
Well, by the same logic we
wrote before, future value--
by the same logic
we wrote before,
if you're going to
have money that's
tiers in the future, the
future value of that money
that you're going to get--
if you're going to basically
take your money and invest it,
you're going to
have money that you
are going to invest
today and put it
in the bank at
some interest rate,
then the future value is the
amount you put in times one
plus the interest rate to the t.
So I've simply
reversed that formula,
present value, future value.
So basically, future value,
if you put money in the bank
at some interest
rate, you're going
to get to have over time
that money times one
plus i to the t.
Now, the reason we write this
formula out and flip it for you
is because I want to highlight
the key feature here that I
want to drill into your heads.
One of the, I don't
know, I guess 10 things
I most care you leave
this course thinking about
if you're not going to major
in economics or remembering--
is the beauty of
compounding, which
is that with a
formula like this,
you earn interest
on your interest.
If you leave money
in the bank, you
don't just earn interest on
the initial amount you put in.
You earn interest on the
interest you earn over time.
OK, and this can be quite large.
So let's do a
simple example just
to show you how big this
can be and to get you
all thinking about what you
should do with your money
when you get a job.
OK, imagine you plan to
work full time from age 22
to age 70.
A little daunting
to think about now.
Probably, most people
will retire after 70
by the time you guys
retire, but let's just
think about 22 to 70.
And let's say that you can save
at a constant 7% interest rate.
Inflation is zero.
The interest rate is constant.
Make life easy.
7% interest rate.
And let's consider two different
plans you have for savings.
Plan one.
Plan one is that
you're going to save
$3,000 a year for the first
15 years that you work
and then stop saving.
3,000 a year for 15
years, then you're
going to leave that in
the bank, leave it alone,
never save anymore.
Just let that money
sit in the bank.
Well in that case,
what will you have?
Well, after the first 15 years
of putting $3,000 in the bank
every year, if you work out the
math, you will have $75,000.
$75,387 after 15 years.
OK, now that's not
just 15 years times--
that's bigger than
15 times 3,000,
because you're earning
interest along the way.
OK, that's those 15 years.
Then, you're just going
to let that sit there.
And that's going to sit there.
Remember, after 15 years--
you started working at 22.
You're only 37 years old.
That's going to then sit
there for the next 33 years.
You're not going to touch it.
You're not going
to save anymore.
What that means
is after 33 years,
this turns into $75,387
times 1.07 to the 33rd.
OK, after 33 years, or $703,000.
703,010.
OK, so you save $3,000.
It's not a lot of money.
You guys can make
a lot of money.
$3,000 for 15 years, and then
you never have to save again.
Contrast that with a
different approach.
Let's say you say, look.
That's stupid.
I'm young.
I'm going to party.
I'll worry about retirement
when retirement is closer.
I'm going to save nothing
the first 15 years,
and then I'm going to
save $3,000 every year.
The first 15 years I'm
going to save nothing,
then I'll save
$3,000 every year.
OK, well if you do
that and do the math,
you end up with when
you retire, $356,800.
Think about this for one second.
In this case, you saved for
more than twice as many years.
You saved for 33 years, and
you ended up with half as much.
That's the miracle
of compounding.
The earlier you
save, the more money
you can make along the way.
And that's why you guys need
to start saving right away.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What was plan two?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Plan two was I
do nothing the first 15 years,
then I save $3,000 a
year for the remaining 30
years of my career.
So literally, in plan
one, I save for 15 years,
and then I stop.
Here, I save for 33 years.
But by starting
earlier and using
the miracle of
compounding, I end up
with twice as much money.
OK, now this is
actually pretty--
this is one of the few
things in this class
my kids could understand
when they were little.
Because have any of you been
to the Boston Science Museum?
Have any of you guys been?
OK, there's a little kid area,
where they've got this ramp.
And you can essentially
drop balls down a ramp.
And one ramp is
flat and then steep,
and one ramp is
steep and then flat.
And of course, the one that's
steep and then flat wins.
It's faster.
And that's just
because of compounding.
That's because acceleration
is compounding.
OK, so basically, the
point is that the earlier
you start saving, the
more money you'll have.
And that's why you guys
should pay attention
when you're offered a
job and offered a 401k
and not think, retirement,
I'll never retire.
You say, no, I want to save now,
because the more I save now,
the more that will compound
by the time I retire.
OK, now you can
actually see this.
It's not just MIT
students who have
to think about this but
professional athletes.
So probably, none
of you have heard
of Bobby Bonilla Any of you
guys heard of Bobby Bonilla?
OK, well if you were 25
years ago in this class,
if you were into
sports, you would
have heard of Bobby Bonilla.
He was a pretty good
player in his time.
And he retired.
But by the end of his career,
he was kind of a slacker.
He wasn't really worth much.
He was playing for the Mets.
And the Mets said, look.
In 1999, they said, look.
We basically want to pay
you off to leave the team.
You have a contract.
We're just going to basically
pay the remaining 5.9 million
on your contract in
1999, give you the money.
Most athletes would've said
great, I'm off to Vegas.
Bobby Bonilla didn't.
He said, well, look.
I've got enough money
right now, but I
might need the money later.
So instead, why don't you defer
the money at an 8% interest
rate and pay me
starting in 2011 when
I'm getting close to
retirement and need the money?
They were like, great.
That's really great.
We don't have to pay you now.
That's great.
Well Bobby Bonilla, by the time
his payments started in 2011,
they'd grown to $30 million.
And every year on a certain
day-- it just passed recently.
They call it Bobby Bonilla.
Bobby Bonilla, who's
now like 70 years old,
gets a million dollar check
from the Mets every year.
Because he was patient enough
to put this off and get
the virtue of compounding.
So this is sort of-- if Bobby
Bonilla, a stupid baseball
player, can do it,
you guys can do it.
So make sure that
you guys are saving
when you start your jobs.
OK, questions about that?
OK, now let's get a
little bit realistic,
and let's recognize that in
life, prices aren't constant,
but rather we have inflation.
And how does that affect
our thinking here?
How does inflation
affect the way
we think about this problem?
Well, it turns out, it
actually adds one step,
but it's actually a pretty
easy step to put in.
It actually turns out
that you can add inflation
without doing a
whole lot of work.
So let's talk about
first what inflation is.
Inflation is the rise in the
price level year over year.
Technically, the inflation
rate is a percentage concept.
It's the percent rise in the
price level year after year.
You might say, the
price level of what?
Of a banana?
Of a computer?
Of what?
Well, what the
government does is they
form something called the
consumer price index, the CPI.
Did I talk about the CPI yet?
OK, I'm sorry.
I just hate repeating myself.
OK, so they form something
called the consumer price
index.
What's the consumer price index?
Literally, the government
every quarter, I believe--
it may be every month--
goes out and gets the prices of
a basket of hundreds of goods.
They literally say, what does a
banana cost this month compared
to last month?
What does a laptop cost
this month compared
to last month, et cetera?
So they go out, and they
price this bundle of goods.
And then literally, they
just ask, how has the price--
they then take a
weighted average
of that bundle, where the
weights are consumer spending.
So consumers spend a lot more
of their income on housing
than bananas.
So the price of housing gets
a lot more weight in the CPI
than does the price of bananas.
Essentially, a weighted
average of prices in society,
and then they create an index.
1982 is normalized
to one, and they just
say how much in
percentage terms did
that weighted average
bundle go up in price?
OK, and you can see
that in Figure 17.1.
Here's historical CPI.
So basically, what
you see is, this
is the level of the CPI,
which is sort of meaningless.
What we care about
is inflation, which
is the year to year
percentage change in the CPI.
And what you can see is,
basically it's going up.
Prices are going up.
It went up very steeply if
you look from 1970 to 1980.
The slope there was much higher
than the slope before or after.
We had very rapid
inflation in the 1970s.
It then has then
since flattened,
and inflation has
been much slower.
And inflation averages
about 3% a year.
OK, so basically, that's
how we measure inflation.
Now, the question
is, how does that
affect our thinking
about present value
if there's actually inflation?
And the bottom line is, we
don't care about dollars.
We care about how
many goods we can buy.
Therefore, it
doesn't matter what's
happening to how
much money we have.
It matters what's happening
to how many goods we can buy.
Therefore, what we
care about is not
what we call the
nominal interest rate.
We care about what we call the
real interest rate, r, which
we define as the nominal
interest rate, which
is what we've been
talking about,
we see advertised on a bank,
minus the rate of inflation,
which for some reason
we use pi, even
though that's also profits.
So sorry about that.
OK, so we define the
real interest rate
as the nominal interest rate
minus the inflation rate.
The real interest rate
is the nominal rate
minus the inflation rate.
And what the real
interest rate measures
is how much more I
have in terms of goods
I can consume, not
how much more I
have in terms of dollars,
which actually in the end
doesn't matter.
OK, so suppose that I'm going
to save $100 at a 10% interest
rate.
Let's go a simple example.
I save $100 at a
10% interest rate.
OK, then next year, I have $110.
But that's irrelevant.
What I want to know is, how
many goods can I buy next year?
So for example, let's say
you spend all your money
on Skittles.
That's all you buy.
OK, and let's say Skittles
cost $1 this year.
And there's no inflation,
so they cost $1 next year.
Then, what that means
with a 10% interest rate
is you can buy 10 more
bags of Skittles next year.
This year, your $100 could
buy you 100 bags of Skittles.
Next year, your $110 can
buy 110 bags of Skittles,
so you are 10% richer.
But now, let's say the price
of Skittles goes up 10%.
Well, what that
means is you can only
buy the same amount
of Skittles next year
as you could buy this year.
You could buy 100 bags this
year and 100 bags next year.
So it doesn't matter that
you have $110 next year.
Who cares?
You only get the same
amount of Skittles.
What you care about is
the goods you can buy.
We wrote down utility.
We didn't put dollars
of utility function.
We put consumption.
So the interest
rate you care about
is the real interest rate.
If the nominal interest rate
is 10% but inflation is 10%,
then the real
interest rate is zero.
You can't buy any
more goods next year.
All the money you made
by putting it in the bank
got eaten up by how much
more expensive things are.
So what that means is,
all the math we've done
and everything we'll talk
about all goes through.
You just need to be thinking
about using the real interest
rate, not the nominal
interest rate.
But otherwise, everything
we've done goes through.
You just need to
essentially think
about this in terms
of how many goods
you can buy, not how
much money you have.
Now, this isn't quite--
let me just take two minutes
and do a little macroeconomics--
this isn't quite as
simple as it sounds,
because of course, you
see in the bank, i,
in the bank window, i.
You don't see pi.
You don't see inflation.
That's what we revealed ex post.
So really, technically--
you don't know this.
It's just for those who care.
You don't have to know
this for the test.
Technically, what you really
want is expected inflation.
When you think of putting
in the money in the bank,
you know you'll learn 3%.
The real interest
rate is that minus
what you think inflation
is going to be.
So it actually
becomes complicated.
It's not as simple.
Ex post, it's easy to find
the real interest rate.
Ex ante, it's not
so easy, because it
depends on what you think
inflation is going to be.
So there's some tricks there.
There's also a bunch of tricks
in measuring the inflation
rate.
So for example, like I said,
the Bureau of Labor Statistics
goes out and has a bundle of
600 goods and gets their prices.
But what is a good?
I mean, a banana is a banana.
But a laptop, what
the hell is a laptop?
How much ram does it have?
What's the graphics card?
How fancy is the display?
Well, the Bureau
of Labor Statistics
doesn't go out and price
literally hundreds of laptops.
It prices one or two.
And the problem with
that is the following.
Let's say you find that
today, a laptop is 1,000,
and tomorrow it's 1500.
But it can do--
let's say today, a laptop is
1,000, and tomorrow, it's 1500.
But it can do a ton more stuff.
Well, we would say
inflation's 50%,
but that's not really right.
Because the good you're
consuming is not the laptop,
it's the computing
ability of the laptop.
And that's gone up.
So to say inflation's
50% is wrong.
Inflation's 50% minus
the quality improvement
of the better laptop you got.
Think of it another way.
Imagine laptop prices didn't
go up, but ram doubled.
Would you say
you're no better off
buying a laptop with twice as
much ram at the same price?
No, you're better off.
But our inflation concept would
say, no, you're the same off.
So the trick here is,
it's simple in practice,
and we'll pretend it's simple
just to say r is i minus pi.
But two tricks-- a,
it's expected pi,
which is hard to guess.
And b, inflation is
really hard to measure,
because there's things like
quality bias and other things.
There's a whole field of
macroeconomics worrying
about inflation measurement,
so we won't spend a lot of time
on it.
But it's just sort
of interesting just
to talk about how at high level
we go through things here.
Like everything
else in this class,
largely, we get it right.
Largely, expected inflation
is not too badly modeled
by last year's inflation.
And quality bias, we
can model and stuff.
So this isn't a bad
model, but it just
points to some of
the subtleties you
have to deal with
in reality when
you try to implement these
basic sort of formulations.
Now, with that in mind,
I'm going to now say,
let's assume inflation
is zero again.
So we'll go back
and use i, and we'll
use i interchangeably with r
for the rest of this course
unless asked differently.
Unless told definitely,
assume inflation is zero,
so i and r are interchangeable.
With that in mind, let's
go to the next topic, which
is taking these tools, how do
we model choices over time?
How do people model?
How do people make
decisions over time?
And there's a simple answer.
So this is tricky, because
if I said to you, hey,
I'm going to give--
do you want $30 or $50?
You would say, I want $50.
But actually, you
shouldn't say that.
You should say, over what period
of time am I getting the 30,
and over what period of
time am I getting the 50?
If it's today, I want 50.
But if the 50 is 20 years in
the future and the 30's today,
I might want the 30.
What that means is, you
have to evaluate choices
in present value terms.
You can't just add
up the money, you
have to evaluate those choices
in present value terms.
And then, you need
to pick the option
with the highest present value.
So once again, let's
come back to athletes,
because athletic contracts
deal with this all the time.
Let's imagine an
athlete considering
two different contracts.
Contract one, contract
a, pays $1 million today.
Contract b pays 500,000 today
and 1.5 million in 10 years.
OK, now when you read
it in the newspaper,
you'll see this guy
got offered a million,
this guy got
offered two million.
That's what the
newspaper will say.
But that's wrong,
because these are
paid at different
periods of times,
so they're different amounts.
Indeed, the present value of
the first contract is what?
$1 million.
It's today.
What's the present value
of the second contract?
Someone tell me how
I'd write that down.
I'd write down the present
value of the second contract.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: 500,000
plus 1.5 million
over one plus whatever the
interest is based on the time.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Exactly.
Which is one plus the
interest rate to the 10,
because you're getting
it in 10 years.
So essentially, that means
that whether it's a better deal
or not depends on
the interest rate.
Indeed, if the
interest rate is 7%,
and the interest
rate is 7%, this
has a present value
of 1.3 million.
So it's a good deal.
If the interest
rate was 14%, then
this deal would have a
present value of 0.9 million.
So it's a worse deal.
So whether or not this
a better or worse deal
depends on the interest rate.
Why is that?
Why is this a worse deal the
higher the interest rate?
AUDIENCE: Because if he'd
gotten the money earlier,
he wouldn't have benefited
from being able to collect
that interest earlier.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Exactly, he
could have invested it earlier,
gotten the compounding, and
had way more money in 10 years.
So the higher the interest
rate, the more you
want to get your money
upfront and save it,
the less valuable is
money in the future.
Now, essentially,
what this says is
that you have to always use
present value to bring things
into current dollars.
Now, this is not an
abstract concept.
Let's take Max Scherzer, who's
a pitcher with the Washington
Nationals.
Max Scherzer a
couple of years ago
signed a seven year $210
million contract, which
he was able to brag was the
second highest ever signed
by a pitcher and the 10th
highest contract ever signed
by any baseball player.
Seven years, 210.
But in fact, that
contract was not--
we're going to pay you $30
million a year for seven years.
It was, we're going
to pay you $15 million
a year for 14 years.
You're going to
play for only seven.
We're going to pay
you over 14 years.
So in fact, in
present value terms,
that was worth somewhat less.
If you use the
current interest rate
when he signed it
which was about 4.7%,
it was only worth
actually 166 million.
Not too shabby, but
suddenly it drops
to the 20th most
valuable baseball
contract and about
fourth among pitchers.
So Max Scherzer was able to feel
better about himself that he
signed this valuable
contract, but in fact, it
was worth less than he thought.
I mean, shed no tears
for Max Scherzer.
He's doing fine.
But it was worth
less than he thought.
Or maybe an example
that's more in our mind
with the Mega Millions--
think about a lottery winner.
So if a Mega Millions
winner gets $290 million,
which sounds like a great deal,
that's paid out over 20 years.
So it's not $290 million,
it's 14 and and a half million
for each of 20 years.
So in present value terms, if
we think about a 7% interest
rate, then that's not 290
million, it's 164 million.
Once again, not too shabby.
OK, but a lot less than
the advertised amount.
So we have to take these dollars
and put them in present value.
So now, here's an interesting
question for that.
If you look at the
recent lottery,
you had a choice of one
person won 1.6 billion,
one person one that, a person
in South Carolina won that.
And they were given a
choice of the 1.6 billion,
which is paid actually
over 30 years,
or a lump sum they
could get right away.
How should they decide which
of those options to take?
How should they decide whether
to take the 1.6 billion
paid over 30 years,
so 1.6 over 30, paid
in equal installments over
time versus just getting a lump
sum today.
Not of 1.6 million,
but a lower amount.
How should they
think about that?
AUDIENCE: They should
evaluate the present value.
JONATHAN GRUBER: They should
add the present value.
They should say, well, what
do I think the interest
rate is going to be?
If I think it's going
to be really low--
let's say the interest
rate is going to be zero.
Then which deal should I take?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER: I should
spread it out over time,
because the money in the future
is worth the same as today,
so I might as well
take the 1.6 billion.
But if I think the
interest rate is
going to be higher, than I
should take the money upfront
and invest that money
and earn my own interest.
So essentially, it
becomes a debate
of what you think the
interest rate is versus
what the state thinks
the interest rate is.
They're setting those two to
be equal under some assumption
of the interest rate.
I don't know what
number they chose.
Whatever number they chose.
It was some number they chose,
because this is our assumption
of the interest rate.
You've got to decide, do you
think the interest rate's
going to be higher or lower?
If you think it's going to be
higher than the state thinks
it is, then you want the money
upfront, and you'll invest it.
If you think it's
going to be lower,
than you should take the money
over time, because the state is
giving you basically
a better deal.
Do you understand that?
OK, so now armed
with this, let's
go and think about how do firms
make investment decisions?
How do firms make
investment decisions?
Remember, investment
is about the delay
of current consumption
for future assumptions.
It's about putting
some aside today
by spending money on a
machine which will deliver
you benefits in the future.
Now, this adds one
wrinkle to what we've
done so far, which is that we've
only talked about money that's
always positive, some amount
you get get in the future.
When you're making an
investment decision,
it's a little bit
more complicated,
because you're actually
spending money today
to make money tomorrow.
So in that case,
we talk about we
call net present value,
which is the same thing,
it just allows for
negative values.
Net present value,
which is essentially
saying in every period,
you want to account
for the cost of that period and
the benefits of that period,
and you want to invest only
if the net present value is
greater than zero.
So for example,
think about a project
that has a stream of payments
in every period of r sub i,
every period it's got a
stream of payments of r sub i,
and a set of costs
that's c sub i.
The costs are the upfront
investments, maybe
the maintenance of the machine.
Whatever it costs to run it.
Then, the net present
value of that investment
is r0 minus c0, comma r1
minus c1 over one plus i--
over one plus i plus r2
minus c2 over one plus i
squared plus dot dot
dot for as many periods
as the investment lasts.
That's the net present
value of an investment.
So basically, what
you want to ask
is, take each period's costs
of benefits into account.
On net, is it greater than zero?
OK, so the key point is
that basically, sometimes
investments which
have upfront costs
can be valuable as
long as the long run
benefits are large enough.
So if you think about an
investment that's got 100--
so think about a simple, trivial
example of the first period
you buy a machine,
and it costs $100.
So c0 is 100.
And let's say for every
period thereafter,
that machine will deliver
you revenues, revenue i--
revenues for i
greater than zero--
of 200.
But it will have
maintenance costs, costs i
greater than zero, of 50.
So what's the net present value?
Well, the net present
value is simply minus 100.
And let's say the machine
is going to last forever.
Minus 100 plus 150 over i.
Think about that for a second.
Basically, what we're saying
is, you're throwing 100 at it
today, so that's negative.
But every period in
the future, you're
going to net $150, because
you're going to make $200
and you have $50
maintenance costs.
And we have the
formula, so we just
apply the formula
for perpetuity.
We have a set of future
payments of $150,
so your net present value is
minus 100 plus 150 over i.
So let's think about, look
at this formula for a second.
What does that say?
What is the relationship
between whether the firm's going
to want to invest and
the interest rate?
What does this imply
the relationship
is between a firm's desire for
investment and the interest
rate?
If the interest rate
goes up, will firms
want to do more investment,
or less investment, and why?
Will firms want to be
more eager to buy machines
or less eager to buy machines,
and why, as the interest
rate goes up?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They'll be less eager.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Less eager.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JONATHAN GRUBER:
They'll be less eager.
Say it again, because why?
AUDIENCE: Because if
they're borrowing.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Yeah,
or I think an easier way
to think of borrowing,
just think about,
they've got a bunch of money.
Apple's got a bunch of money
today they're sitting on.
If they buy the machine, they're
going to get this return.
If they don't buy the machine,
they could put it in the bank
or invest it in Apple stock
and get some interest rate, i.
The higher the interest rate,
the less they want invest.
Or think of it this way.
The interest rate is the
opportunity cost of investment.
The more the firm invests
in their machines,
the less they can earn saving
through some other mechanism.
And the price that
they pay by foregoing
that other savings is i.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So does that mean if
you're looking at a machine,
it's better to try to
then push the cost further
into the future, because then
they can't also divide by
the [INAUDIBLE] sign?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Basically, you always want
to try to make as much
money early as you can
and make the cost
as late as you can.
For any given amount, you'd
absolutely like to do that.
That's why we'll talk about
this in my public finance class.
We talk about why, when
you're paying taxes,
you always want to try to
find shenanigans that allow
you to pay your taxes later.
So for any given
amount of taxes,
the later you pay
it, the less it
costs you, because you get to
earn the interest along the way
and then pay it later on.
This is a key
macroeconomic concept.
You'll often hear in the
news, high interest rates
are bad for business.
And you might have
thought, why is that?
This is why.
High interest rates are bad
for the economy, you'll hear.
Why are high interest
rates bad for the economy?
You might say, wait a second.
That makes no sense.
A high interest rate means
I earn more on my savings.
Why is that bad for the economy?
It's bad for the
economy, because it
lowers the demand for capital.
Because the higher
the interest rate,
the less firms actually
want to invest.
The more they just want to stock
their money away in the bank.
So that is the key question.
Now, then let me ask
another question.
If you're a firm, what's
the right i to use?
If you're a firm thinking
about this investment decision,
we know the higher i is,
the less you want invest.
But what is i?
Once again, forget inflation.
Inflation is zero.
What's the right what we
call firm discount rate?
The discount rate is
the amount by which
firms are going to discount
future dollars to bring them
back to today.
How does the firm think
about what i to use?
What i should the firm use?
Your Apple.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] i that
makes that positive, right?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Well, they don't want
to invest unless it's positive.
That's a good point.
But the way that is,
they write down the math,
and they plug in an i.
What i do they plug in?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is it published
by the government?
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Well, i might be.
But there's not one answer.
What's the general answer
the firm wants to use?
What's the general answer?
That the firm-- if
you're a firm thinking
about making an
investment, you want
to discount that investment.
What do you want
to discount it by?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: The opportunity
cost of the next best return.
JONATHAN GRUBER: The next
best thing you could do.
So if I'm thinking about
buying this machine,
when I discount
it, I want to think
about what's the next best thing
I could do with that money?
That's the discount
rate I want to use.
So in a world where firms
either can buy a machine
or put it in the
bank, it's easy.
It's the bank interest rate.
But life's not that easy.
Firms have dozens
of investments.
So for every
investment, you want
to discount it by
the next best thing
you can do with the money.
It's the concept of
opportunity cost.
That's why it's the very first
thing we taught in this class.
Opportunity cost is
always what drives things.
Questions about that?
Now, this isn't just for firms.
This same math applies
to consumers as well.
Let's think about me.
A number of years
ago, I had to decide
whether to insulate
my ancient house.
Let's write down the numbers
to think how this worked.
I had heating
bills at that time,
back when gas was
cheaper, of about $2,000
a year was my heating
bills for the house.
The best estimate
I could get was
that if I insulated
my house, I would
lower my heating costs by 25%.
So my heating costs would
fall by $500 per year
if I escalated my house.
But to insulate my house, I had
to pay the guy to insulate it.
And the insulation cost $4,000.
How do I think about whether
I should insulate or not?
How do I think
about that decision?
What equation
should I write down?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Minus 4,000
plus 500 over i.
JONATHAN GRUBER: Exactly.
I should say, I'll
assume I'm going
to own the house forever, or
at least long enough that I
can treat it as forever.
And I write down that formula.
And what that formula
says is that if I
think the interest rate is less
than 12.5%, I should insulate.
If I think the interest
rate is more than 12.5%,
I should just invest the
money and use the returns
that I invested to pay
my higher heating bills.
So it all depends on what
the interest rate is.
So that's why-- I did it.
I insulated.
So the same logic
we can think of
is basically, essentially
the same idea as firms.
You want to think about the
upfront costs and the long run
returns.
And here's a fun
economics question.
What if I don't intend to
hold the house forever?
I would argue I should
still use this formula.
Why?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Because whenever
you decide to sell the house,
you increase the value.
JONATHAN GRUBER:
Exactly, because I'm
increasing the value of an
asset that I'll then sell.
So presumably, by
insulating, I've
raised the price of my house.
How much have I raised it by?
Exactly 500 over i, so I'm going
to insulate and sell next year.
I should still
insulate, because I
should get 500 over i
more dollars for my house.
So in fact, it doesn't matter.
If you can sell an
asset, then actually
your horizon is always infinite.
It's not just the
short horizon, which is
kind of an interesting insight.
So the last thing I
want to talk about
is the fact that these
decisions are not
just relevant-- you guys
are like retirement,
business machines, insulation--
god, you're old, John.
I don't care about
any of this stuff.
Well, let's talk about
something you care about,
which is going to college.
Let's talk about your decision.
You've already made it, but
you've got a little sibling,
and they're deciding
whether to go to college.
And they're not
going to go to MIT.
They're going to go to
a more typical school.
And they've got to decide
whether to go to college.
Well in fact, their decision
is an investment decision,
just like any other
investment decision.
What they're
investing in is what
we call their human capital.
When you get education, you're
investing in yourself, just
like you invest in a machine.
Because you are,
you hope, raising
the value of what you can
do, of what you can earn,
by investing in learning stuff.
Well, that human
capital investment
has the same features
of any other investment.
There's an opportunity
cost, which is what?
What's the opportunity
cost of investing your time
in going to college--
what's the opportunity
cost of going to college?
AUDIENCE: You could get a job.
JONATHAN GRUBER: You could--
there's two.
One is, you can get a job.
AUDIENCE: You could also
invest your tuition.
JONATHAN GRUBER: You
could not pay tuition.
So if you think about
going to college,
you're sacrificing two things.
All that money
you're paying, you
could basically invest instead
of giving it to some college.
And you could be out earning
money instead of sitting here
listening to me.
OK, so if you think
about that, it actually
becomes a harder decision
than you might think.
So let's think about
a simple example.
Let's imagine that if
you don't go to college,
you work from age 18 to 70.
And if you do go to college,
you work from age 22 to 70.
So we're going to
ignore grad school.
Four years of college, you
either start working at 18,
or you start working at 22.
And let's say college
costs $35,000 a year.
Obviously, not MIT.
OK, let's say college
costs $35,000 a year.
And let's say that if you
worked starting in high school,
you could have earned $20,000.
You could have
started at $20,000
if you'd gone to work at age 18.
Well, we can actually
graph what this
looks like in figure 17.2 17.2.
If you think about age
18, from age 18 to age 22,
that's the green area.
If you go to
college, you give up
the $35,000 in tuition and the
20,000 you could have earned.
The bottom line is
basically-- the red line
is your lifetime earnings
if you go to high school,
if you don't go to college.
The blue line is your
lifetime earnings
if you do go to college.
Empirical estimates
suggest that at age 22,
the typical college
graduate earns $45,000.
Yes, you're not the
typical college graduate.
The typical college
graduate earns $45,000.
And the typical high school
non-college education person
earns $28,000.
So at age 22, you come
out of college earning 45,
and if you'd not gone
to college, you earn 28.
Not you, but a normal person.
But moreover, knowledge you earn
more when you leave college,
your earnings grows faster.
So if you're college
educated, it not only
means you earn
17,000 more at 22,
it also means your
earnings grows faster.
So that by age 51, the average
college educated person
earns $80,000, while
the average high school
person earns $45,000.
So what you see here
is, the blue line
starts above the red line
and the gap widens over time.
And maybe, I would have
learned to clip this
on if I hadn't gone to college.
OK, so the gap widens over time.
So how do we think
about this decision?
Well, the cost is
the green area.
The cost is over four years,
you could have earned money
and you wouldn't have
had to pay tuition.
The benefit is the yellow area.
Over that entire time
after graduation,
you're making more money.
Now obviously, in terms
of size, the yellow area
is much, much bigger
than the green area.
But the yellow area comes later.
That's the key thing.
So if I look and say,
look, it's obvious--
before this lecture,
you might say, well,
it's obvious you
should go to college.
Look, the yellow is way
bigger than the green.
But that's not necessarily true,
because the green comes now,
and the yellow comes later.
Indeed, if you
look at the table,
this actually shows
the net present value
of going to college
and high school.
And what this shows is
at low interest rates,
you're much better
off going to college.
So if there's interest
rate, then college
is a much, much better deal.
Your net present
value of earnings
if if you go to
college is 2.6 million,
while it's only 1.6 million
if you don't go to college.
But once the interest
rate gets above 8%,
it suddenly becomes a worse
deal to go to college.
That is at only a 9% interest
rate, which existed not that
long ago in our history.
It was actually a worse
deal for the average person
to go to college.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that not
accounting for financial aid,
though?
Because if you didn't
have the 35,000 to spend,
you wouldn't have been
able to invest it?
JONATHAN GRUBER: Well,
actually, it's interesting.
It depends on the
form of financial aid.
Why?
Someone tell me why it's
dependent on the form
of financial aid?
Financial aid comes
in different forms.
So why does it depend on how
you get the financial aid?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because if
you have to pay it back.
JONATHAN GRUBER: If
it's a grant, then yeah,
you should just take
that out of the cost.
But if it's a loan, it
depends what interest
rate you get the loan at.
If the loan is at the
market interest rate,
then it's no different.
But that's a great point, which
is why college financial aid
comes in two forms.
Grants for very low income
people, and low interest loans
for other people.
Why do we give low
interest loans for college?
Because of this graph.
Because we're saying,
we think people need
to invest in their education.
We're afraid that if they
faced a regular interest rate,
they won't be willing to do
it, because the green would
be bigger than the yellow.
So we're actually going to
subsidize their interest rate.
So you might have thought to
yourself, sort of a weird way
to get people to go to college
is to have a lower student loan
interest rate.
But in fact, it
makes perfect sense.
By having a student
loan interest
rate that's lower
than the market rate,
you encourage people
to go to college,
because essentially you
lower this discount rate,
at least on the part
that's tuition payments.
So that's actually very
exciting way to think about
and a very important
part of public policy
is how we set the interest
rate on student loans.
For any of you-- how many of
you guys have a student loan?
Do you know?
Any of you guys
have a student loan?
You might not know.
Anyway, I set the interest
rate on that student loan.
So thank you.
Actually, when I was
in the government,
I was in the
government 14 months,
the Clinton Administration.
It was super fun.
But looking back, I
only got one thing done,
which I got to set the interest
rate for student loans.
So that was kind of fun.
But otherwise, it was just
a lot of fun being there.
So anyway, let's stop
there, and we will continue.
What's today, Wednesday?
So no class on Monday.
That's Veterans Day, so we'll
meet in a week, next Wednesday.